I wish I knew this in high school I got
so much I would have all these articles
oh Bart save the world again
[Music]
all right so we've done articles like
this before but we never actually sat
with somebody in the room who actually
has an only fans account this is another
case we have so many questions school
that suspends a boy
after finding his mom's only fan oh
that's nice they suspended the boy that
makes no sense that's [__] up fun fact
most girls buy those articles and make
up fake [__] so they can get subscribers
so chances are oh I never thought of
that
Insider unless it's fact checked it
probably didn't happen never thought of
that genius marketing holy [__]
so it's like now I got to search up who
this hot mom is yeah especially
it's hot like that photo was hot I just
looked at it like she she bought that
she bought that article right because
it's usually never a show the photos or
say the username I need to see the photo
though for real we have a code of
conduct
she can choose and put that on the
article yeah dope ass angle yeah
basically you can pay like Publications
like a lot of journalists just let you
pay them to like create articles but a
lot of these people or girls are like
all right what's something newsworthy
like I got fired for being a teacher
although some of them actually did get
fired for being a teacher but like if
you're buying articles but they're
putting out the story themselves pretty
much I wish I knew this in high school I
got so much [__] I would have all these
articles oh but save the world again
yeah
Asian man with biggest penis
part the master of cunnilingus he
cleaned up all the chlorine in Ohio
[Laughter]
Gabriel man loses virginity again
holy [__] that's tight hey Bart what's
up man that's crazy how fast you were
able to call that up yeah what do you
feel like the percentage of like these
types of articles that go out are ads
versus like actual stories then if it's
actually
the hot pick made sense though because
usually your pick sucks for these things
it's like a mug shot yeah or something
yeah but uh what gives it away is most
like newsworthy like
all right I'm trying to think about the
word but most like uh journalists don't
write on only fans because it [__] with
their credibility
like the chief editors like why are you
writing those articles if you're like an
esteemed respected journalist yeah
you're not writing about only fans
unless it's something like journalists
would love to expose like the dark side
of only fans or something like that but
most articles aren't going to be like
wow a school suspends boy after finding
his mom this girl did a good job to me
because I was like they suspended the
boy yeah
it's the new angle dude they she got me
on but it also sounds realistic like it
could happen does it like a boy getting
suspended unless it's like a Christian
cat like a Christian school or something
that's what I was thinking like which we
just had a whole conversation with you
about stuff similar he's the one showing
everybody then yeah he's like look at
how hot my
is guys they should expel that I know as
a young boy
Christian Schools kick you out for any
reason we're having bangs really
yeah oh when you had these ones yep oh
yeah maybe his mom was like yo go
promote my [__] dude yeah
they think I'm hot right man well then
she'd probably go to jail to be fair
yeah oh yeah I was behind under G-Wagon
payments
have you purchased an ad or anything
like that of any peculiar nature um I
I'm bought like world star posts I've
bought
um like big Instagram porn stars I've
like bought ads from them I try to get
like a few articles like this but I at
the time did not think about how to
Market it so they were [__] shitty
articles
what's a good headline what's what's
your headline yeah Dad son's only fans
girl her own nudes
really good
that girl makes horse come from riding
the back
yeah give me an equestrian and then you
send the video of the horse falling girl
you're riding from the top but the horse
came somehow or you're eliminated
it's right next to Bart save the world
again
magazine dude
myself from like bestiality oh yeah
my niece it's two Japanese
that's really good though your angle
about uh uh dad sends that could be a
really good [__] article though
here's the only thing thing is my dad
already thinks I've embarrassed him
enough and I have and it's like I don't
want to just seem like I'm exploiting
all of my family's problems although I
do talk about it a lot but it's like you
know he's been on Forbes like he is
successful at what he does and like I've
already I'm already embarrassed him he's
only offense cup
Manhattan Beach I feel like everyone
their successful right yeah they're all
rich unless they live in apartments what
does your dad do owns like a Chick-fil-A
or something
he's on board for a franchise team one
year a lot of money Christian chicken
sandwich shop that's true do they rake
it in each one of them make like two
Finance stuff he's a finance bro yeah
he's a West Coast Wall Street guy
so he's gotta at least be proud of like
your ability to make yeah dude that's
still your thing
though he probably don't know your
numbers huh um I don't know well I
wonder if those numbers would phase him
if he's a Wall Street yeah he might be
like cute he'd just be like oh okay no
honestly I I'm like 25 and gonna make
almost as much as him I think by the end
of the year or next year
buy out his feelings buy a Forbes
magazine article that's [__] dope
that's gangster that talks about that's
the article right there yeah that's what
I'm saying that's a Forbes article
there's a difference between doing like
a random like you know only fans
daughter buys father's hedge fund and
fires why is controlling interest in
mother's company my [__] it was opposite
almost any job I found I would have made
more than my dad
like hey I work at Fry's
you got the outfit so you think you're a
big shot now
[Laughter]
you know how much she made every year my
dad yeah yeah like his so he was a car
dealer at Commerce Casino and the way
they have it split up kind of sucks
where I saw his like pay stubs it's
literally just minimum wage so they make
most of their money off of tips like a
waiter but tips is actually quite a bit
yeah because this is also a minimum wage
was like six dollars huh exactly dude
yeah dude that's what my dad was like he
was like no I can't buy that [__] but
I'm [__] Paul I look at it I'm like
[__] you hard for dude
because my mom was a liar my mom works
at like a Forbes or a Fortune 500
company and she's not up there but she
has like one of those like like pretty
steady union jobs where she probably
made like I don't know like 80 to like
100 a year yeah yeah and then so my mom
what did she say in your dad well they
no they split oh they got divorced when
I was young but then I thought that
would get a bigger laugh
no you know you're right
so they got divorced and my mom would
bust the same [__] all the time but then
I would see her checkbook I'm like what
do you mean he got hella money in there
you [__] liar
just accusing the [__] out of them oh I
can't buy it doesn't have any money what
the [__] literally says like [__] 50
000 or something
I'm just trying to get a 50 walk man
what do you mean
you got 50 Keys just chilling damn dude
that's why they don't tell you but every
time I ask my parents what they made
when I was a kid they didn't want to
tell me my mom told me straight up
what'd she say she's like I'm raising
you on [__] 20 grand oh [__] and then
my brother because I she's like I can't
pay for your college I already paid for
your brothers I don't have any more
money so I went to get financial aid and
[__] and then they told me that his
dumbass could have gone to the financial
aid office and my mom didn't have to pay
he could have got a free [__] Grant
or whatever if your parents split you
you're like at a different category yeah
and I was like you
[__] she didn't have to pay for your
college but the perhaps the phone to
form so confusing
dude I remember when I filled out my
fast form for the first time for college
you know how it says like how much your
parents have to pay yeah at the bottom
and said my parents had to pay for 700
right and I thought that was a win I was
like oh my God we don't have pain uh
your middle class yeah we got paid by
the government that no but that's
literally like uh just how much they
have to afford because everything else
was loans and I wasn't I wasn't sure
it's not like I was getting a
scholarship
you're gonna pay it later but in my mind
I was just like oh they don't have to
pay that much like cool like I did a
good job yeah but it was like I
qualified for a hella debt is off but
what's what was the car what was the
total cost of UCI at the time that you
went to apologies oh you're smart yeah
he's a little brainy that was maybe like
at the time
I was anywhere from like 15 to 21 000 or
something like that eight years yeah oh
but you would always get some sort of
Grant like I would you would it was easy
to Pell Grant or yeah it was easy for
1500 like 3 000 in Grants at least and
then the everything else was a full-on
loan and it's paid it's all paid off now
now it is yeah
[Music]